welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler
and we have a lot to cover in this
podcast episode so
uh first i think we should begin by
clearing the air and uh providing some
information to the audience obviously
last week um there was a late episode uh
it didn't go up on a thursday it went up
on a friday which you know
is kind of a dead giveaway that
something weird was going on when i run
the ship it's usually a well-oiled
machine things get posted on time
uh it was a rough episode when you're
when you're actually around to run the
ship
correct so i just so the audience is
aware i went on a very brief uh very
well-earned vacation it was a long
weekend
and a lot happened in just a short
period of time it was 72 very eventful
hours where uh i left town um
and i mean do you want to fill people in
i mean i just i think it's important to
cover this because
you know for the last three years i've
been
making art and trying to build something
that's beautiful and something that uh
helps people
and in about 72 hours you nearly threw
that all away
i wouldn't say that i would say for the
last three years you've been a
domineering overlord
[Music]
like most bosses just completely
throttling the people who work under you
and so i and all of the other stronger
by science podcast guest co-hosts got
together in your absence and we
unionized so uh while eric was away me
and all of the other guest co-hosts that
have been on the show
we got together we
joined the screen actors guild sag as a
subsidiary for fitness podcast co-hosts
and uh we presented eric with a union
contract
that uh
you know he was basically forced to sign
because
as much as i hate to admit it
you are a talented podcaster but
you can't do it alone you need your your
stable your bevy of uh podcast co-hosts
to to to keep the the wheels turning you
know keep things moving along so we
presented you with a contract that you
essentially had to sign if you wanted
the show to go on
and uh yeah so now we have uh
re-entered a working relationship now on
more equitable footing no longer can
management keep its foot on the throat
of uh all of the other workers on this
podcast and i i think
overall it will be for the best
yeah so just to give people
a more
just to give people look into my
perspective here so
about
a day into my vacation uh my
email inbox is just getting flooded with
uh you know messages i'm getting paper
mail sent to my vacation destination
saying
eric what happened to the podcast it's
terrible this is i mean the ratings were
tanking you can look on itunes it you
really
it was really a mess who you brought on
here
but i i can see that things are are
going wrong i contacted my legal team
they told me that surprisingly what you
did was uh largely legal and i didn't
have much recourse
and i was eager to get to the
negotiating table because
um i lost access to all the accounts i
think that that was
not an appropriate way to handle things
well if you set your password as
password uh it's not too hard to crack
but that is still illegal hacking even
if you did guess that eight uh eight
character password but anyway uh we got
to the negotiating table and i we
definitely can't move forward in a way
that i would say is friendly but
we have reached a professional agreement
and that's going to involve some title
changes so um
greg for now
is the permanent guest
co-host
and i am the special temporary primary
host
so i think that those are really
self-explanatory and very
straightforward probably no need to
elaborate um and
and when you say for now
those are our titles for the next three
years until we have to come back to the
table and renegotiate the union contract
[Music]
and at that point if you lock us out and
call in pinkerton's uh
you know there might be some scenes that
are more reminiscent of early 1900s
labor history so uh just be prepared for
that
yeah and that's not the only change
there are also some profit sharing
ramifications uh the that document that
you placed on my table um
which i signed basically under duress
you made a cash grab so up until this
point i had been taking 100
of the bulk supplements riches that have
been coming our way because as the only
host of the show i think that makes
sense
um but given the new contract that's in
place at least for now uh the podcast
co-host union is going to be getting
five percent of the profit from that
arrangement and that is moving forward
that's not we're not going to go
retroactively and calculate all that um
so i i think um
it is what it is and we will push
forward and do our best and try not to
let our personal issues bleed into the
show because the show is about the
viewers and the listeners okay for sure
i just have two things to add first uh
you mentioned signing the contract under
duress i just want to get this on the
record for anyone in law enforcement who
is watching or listening to this right
now the gun that i was holding to his
head as he signed those papers wasn't
loaded and just a quick bit of legal
advice for anyone listening to this
podcast threatening someone with an
unloaded firearm is actually completely
legal
so
any anytime you want to get something in
life just make sure you take the bullets
out and that's actually totally fine a
lot of people don't know that
second thing is this is actually a
pretty historic moment uh within
a single week the first uh amazon
shop unionized and
the first fitness podcast co-host union
started uh so this is this is really a
momentous time in labor history
yeah and i'm gonna have to go update the
disclaimer at the end of the show and
say we're we're not dietitians we're not
medical doctors and would you believe it
we're also not lawyers
so do not take medical legal or any
other type of advice from this show
um all right so if you like the show and
you want to support it of course you can
like rate and subscribe wherever you
access it
if you would like to help me personally
you could use the discount code sbs pod
over at
bulksupplements.com that'll get you a
five percent discount off of your order
and i need that now more than ever now
that i'm sharing a small portion of
those profits with the union uh in
addition to support the show you could
sign up at the mass research review or
you could subscribe to the macro factor
diet app
all right for the content of this show
we're going to dive right in we've got
a nice q a episode we've got a quite a
few listener questions that we'd like to
answer so uh greg you want to do the
honors and start us off here i i do
actually have a bit of a feats of
strength segment oh wow cool
yeah so there there have been some big
numbers hit recently uh starting with
the biggest raw deadlift of all time or
yeah there hasn't been a bigger equipped
deadlift than this in powerlifting
either i don't believe uh danny grigsby
uh deadlifted
465 kilos or 1025 pounds uh in a meet
about a week ago
um as mentioned biggest uh deadlift in
powerlifting history that breaks
benedict magnuson's long-standing record
of a thousand and fifteen
and i gotta say this record
was was good i i was i i'm a big fan of
benny magnuson but i think
it was good to see his record fall
because
you know it was the biggest deadlift in
powerlifting history and it was
through no fault of benny's a somewhat
sketchy record um
it was set in a meet
that was it was set in a meet from a fed
that was notorious for lifters you know
doing an invitational meet for that fed
i think it was called hardcore
powerlifting
hitting huge numbers and then never
hitting them again
and i don't believe this has been
confirmed but there are rumors that
maybe the plates used in those meets
were special plates that had been uh
somewhat calibrated to go in the
lifter's favor
so they're calibrated but not
necessarily in the way you'd think
they're precise but not accurate
yeah
calibrated but not appropriately
calibrated so um
yeah i don't think that was ever fully
confirmed but there were enough lifters
who were you know really high level guys
would set like a 50-pound pr in one of
those meets and then never hit those
numbers again so
you know
it is what it is um
so regardless i i don't think there are
any uh any asterisks on this record and
also set in a full power meet so a lot
of deadlift records are set in deadlift
only meets where the lifter just shows
up warms up pulls a big deadlift goes
home
which you know lets you be a little bit
fresher from not having to squat and
bench beforehand this was done in a full
power meet as well
so
you'll love to see it very good deadlift
and you should check that out
also recently there was um
a big meet uh here in america from
you know i haven't been following all of
the usapl ipf drama as closely as i
should have but i i think that this was
essentially a meet
for top level
kind of ex usa pl lifters like people
who are um
or maybe this is just the new ipf
affiliated fed in the us i'm not totally
sure whatever big meat recently a lot of
strong people there uh and the talk of
the town from that meet was uh jesus
olaveras
um
so okay so
jesus hit a big total and then there are
going to be two french people after this
i debated before we started recording do
i try to pronounce names correctly or
not
i
an unfortunate thing about being a
southerner
is when i try to pronounce uh foreign
names or words correctly it just sounds
like i'm doing a really bad racist
accent so uh
whatever
he's jesus and i'm not trying to do
better than that uh anyway huge total uh
he totaled uh
1110 kilos which i believe is only two
and a half kilos under uh ray williams
current world record um
but the thing to keep in mind is jesus
is only 23 years old whoa so he has a
ton of room to keep growing and
improving in the sport um
squatted close to a grand 450 kilos
binged 560 something deadlifted high
eights um so just huge performance all
around uh and there's still so much room
to grow in the sport from him
then also last month uh the french
powerlifting nationals took place and
there were there were several huge
performances but i think probably the
two most impressive were from a couple
of the lightweight women in the
competition so tiffany
chapan
uh she totaled
um
[Music]
921 and a half pounds uh for a new world
record in the 105 or the 103 weight
class i should say and also she broke
chin wei ling's
long-standing squat record in that
weight class which
uh
you know you go back five years like
that was one of the strongest and
apparently most untouchable lifts on the
books like it was a big outlier like
that squat record
so taking out that squat record and
uh chin whaling's total in the same meet
very very impressive
and then naomi ala bear uh she totaled
981 uh in the
114 pound weight class
and uh she she also squatted uh 363
which i believe was a world record as
well um so two
two huge performances there um
you know i think french powerlifting is
is on the come-up right now um
we've also mentioned
what is her name
uh bivoli i forget her last her first
name
anyway uh there's another very very top
level uh
female french lifter right now i think
in the 152 class and there are there are
a couple other um
like youth or junior
male deadlifters who are putting up some
crazy numbers as well so in terms of uh
countries to watch in powerlifting
france is on the come up uh don't sleep
on the french
good stuff all right uh do you want to
jump into your q a or do you want me to
kick things off now you can kick it off
all right so i had mentioned in a
previous episode that i was going to
cover this topic so i wanted to make
sure i covered it first so it didn't get
pushed to yet a later episode
so i got a question from marvik samut
the question was uh how do protein
requirements scale
is 70 grams per day really within the
optimal range for a 40 kilogram person
conversely do
150 kilogram behemoths
really need upwards of 300 grams
um
so this is a good question and
you might be a bit surprised to learn
that
there's not as much uh direct evidence
related to this question as as you might
expect um you know it seems like a
pretty fundamental pretty foundational
question
um so i want to dive into it because i i
um
you know i've seen this debate happen uh
on the internet in a few different
places and there's usually a couple
studies that get kicked around that are
informative to lean on um one study that
comes up a lot
when people are basically arguing
against the idea of scaling protein in
any way so some people say hey let's
scale protein to fat free mass let's
scale it to total body mass sometimes
people say no need to scale whatsoever
flat dose everyone has basically the
same protein requirements for for
optimizing hypertrophy and a lot of
times they'll point to a study by
mcnaughton and colleagues from 2016
and the title of the study is the
response of muscle protein synthesis
following whole body resistance exercise
is greater following 40 grams than 20
grams of ingested whey protein and the
title kind of gives away what they were
getting at but what they're trying to do
is assess how lean body mass
influenced protein needs and so it was
kind of your classic acute study looking
at you know single meal protein
synthesis occurring in the resistance
trained state
uh and they were looking at 20 gram
versus 40 gram doses of whey protein
and they were looking at how responses
differed in people with low lean body
mass versus high lean body mass and
these uh they sampled resistance trained
males
and they basically divided it into two
groups so the the individuals with lower
lean body mass were less than or equal
to 65 kilograms of lean body mass and
the high lean body mass group was 70
kilograms or greater
and so uh in randomized order the
individuals in these two different
groups would you know do resistance
training and then take a protein dose of
either 20 or 40 grams
so what they found within this study
was that there really wasn't strong
evidence to suggest that the protein
needs were necessarily greater in the
individuals who had higher lean body
mass
however there are some
pretty important and pretty
straightforward caveats for this study
first of all it was looking at muscle
protein synthesis not hypertrophy and
looking at that over a short period of
time previously on the show i've talked
about this a lot i've written about it
in a lot of depth in the mass research
review but we have to be really cautious
about assuming that acute snapshots of
muscle protein synthesis are necessarily
going to be perfectly predictive of
longitudinal hypertrophy outcomes we
have to be really careful about treating
those things as if they're truly
synonymous and interchangeable
another shortcoming or kind of
limitation of the study is that they
only looked at two protein doses it was
20 versus 40 grams if you know when we
look at studies that are trying to
establish
protein requirements for optimization
usually
you you see a lot of different protein
doses in the mix so usually like we'll
see some of the studies that look at
identifying uh you know total protein
needs for the entire day and they'll
look at it as a continuous variable and
say okay we see that as you go up and up
and up with the protein dose at this
point you know you've basically maxed
things out or or you've achieved a near
optimal or near maximal response so in
this case we're only looking at these
two doses here
which doesn't allow us a lot of
granularity for identifying a really
tiny difference in this group versus
that group
another issue
or limitation i should say is that fat
free mass obviously was dichotomized
here so there was a group with low lean
body mass or low fat free mass and a
group with high
so it was dichotomized in these two
groups rather than just kind of leaving
it as a continuous variable and looking
at the relationship you know
if you're trying to if you had all the
resources in the world and you could set
up a study like this however you wanted
to
ideally what you would like to do
is in my opinion leave fat free mass as
a continuous variable try a wide range
of several different protein doses and
really look at that relationship in a
more granular way where you can say
here's the relationship between protein
dose and fat free mass and how how
different responses
are observed in these different um
uh combinations of those variables
uh and so one thing i will say so i i'm
as you know uh very sympathetic to
uh dichotomizing a continuous variable
not being good practice
i personally don't think that's as big
of an issue in this particular study as
it is in many studies because
one like one of the drawbacks of
dichotomizing a continuous variable is
like at the break point sometimes you
can have people sorted into different
groups who are basically the same you
know like um you know if you were
dichotomizing people by bench press
strength like maybe you have someone who
bench presses
230 in a high bench press strength group
and someone who benches 225 in a low
bench press strength group and it's like
yeah it's basically the same in this
study they did have a five kilo dead
zone
um
so like they didn't have any subjects
who had between 65 and 70 kilos of lean
mass so they they did at least
make sure that the highest lean body
mass low lean low lean body mass person
uh was at least five kilos away from the
lowest lean body mass hyaline body mass
person yeah and also the mean
differences between groups
were larger than the total range within
each group so the low lean body mass
group it was uh 59.3 kilos on average
versus 76.9 so that's a difference of
what
a little bit over 17 kilos of lean body
mass so like that that's a that's a
pretty big difference and the range
within each group was about 13 kilos so
like i i do think that um you know
keeping it a continuous variable and
using a regression approach would have
been preferable but i i do think uh they
wound up with two groups that were
were considerably different yeah and
meaningfully so yeah so what i aim to do
here is just kind of lay out all of the
limitations but not necessarily um
indicating that they are of equal
importance
um so
i i think having that dead zone is quite
important and and so you do get
you get past that issue where you have
people in two different groups who are
virtually identical with the uh you know
uh independent variable of interest here
so so that is definitely a good point to
bring up um but but i think sometimes
people look at this study
as saying oh there's no point in
revisiting this question like we've
already got the research lean body mass
it doesn't matter if you have a ton or a
little you know 20 grams or 40 grams
whatever the case is enough to max
things out no big deal no need to worry
about it beyond that and i think
sometimes people
neglect to dig into the details of this
study and recognize we're talking about
15 participants per group split into
these two different groups looking at
only two different protein doses this is
far from the type of study where you
would say it is an open and shut case
and there is no need to revisit that
question you know so there are several
things that you could nitpick certain
things that are bigger limitations than
others ultimately i personally think the
two biggest limitations are
anytime you're talking about a study
with 15 people per group and saying yeah
let's use this as a universally true
finding that we don't need to revisit
obviously 15 people per group is not
going to give you that level of
confidence
and then also the fact that it's looking
at acute muscle protein synthesis rather
than an indicator of direct hypertrophy
i think those are the two biggest
reasons that we should uh you know
appreciate this study for sure uh and
appreciate the effort that went into
conducting it and you know yielding
these results
but it's far from an open and shut case
you know
and so in answering this question about
how we should scale
protein recommendations i think it's
potentially more informative to look at
daily protein targets rather than meal
by meal targets
it gives us more data to work with
there's just not a lot of these
experimental studies looking at meal by
meal different lean body mass values and
different protein servings and things
like that there's just not as much to
work with
but i think if we step back and we look
at the research on
total daily protein targets and how
different intakes lead to different
results we can start to play around with
how scaling might influence some of
these things so i think it's helpful to
step away from the meal by meal focus
and look at the day by day focus and see
how different intakes re relate to
actual changes in hypertrophy over time
i think that can be really informative
so you know the kind of the classic
paper that we talk about all the time
we talk about its strengths and its
weaknesses you know depending on the
conversation uh but there's a study by
morton and colleagues the meta
regression and they scaled their protein
recommendation to body mass just total
weight
and they identified that their kind of
recommended range for protein intake for
supporting hypertrophy over time was 1.6
to 2.2 grams per kilogram and what's
really convenient about that
recommendation
is that it matches up really well with a
study by bandigan and colleagues which
was looking more mechanistically at kind
of a shorter time scale so instead of
looking at
hypertrophy over time it was a more lab
based mechanistic study about okay how
much over a short time scale is enough
to kind of support these anabolic
processes to an optimal degree and they
found that their recommended range was
in that range of like 1.7 to 2.2 grams
per kilogram so what's nice about these
studies is that there's some overlap
there
and what we can do if we feel so
inclined you know if you make some
assumptions
and some generalizations about the body
composition of individuals in those
studies you can kind of back calculate
a range that is roughly scaled to fat
free mass
and you could argue about exactly what
assumptions you should make and and you
know how you should do that calculation
but
i would say that these
two studies would suggest that generally
speaking 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram
within these samples worked pretty well
and that would be equivalent to
somewhere in the range of 2 to 2.75
grams per kilogram of fat free mass if
you chose to scale to that now
you might wonder why these two studies
uh by morton and bandigan uh scaled to
body mass
and i really i'm not certain to be
honest um
you know it's very possible that they
were just staying in line with the
standard practice you know the rda the
the recommended uh what does that stand
for recommended dietary allowance i
think something along those lines uh the
rda
is you know basically what they say here
this is kind of a generic protein amount
that
an adult should consume to to make sure
they have enough pro protein to just you
know be healthy you know not not have
any adverse uh consequences of
insufficient protein so
it's very possible they were just kind
of staying in line with the rda and
scaling to body mass so that it could be
a nice apples to apples comparison so
they could say oh actually if you're a
lifter you need at least double the rda
on the same kind of scaling footing so
to speak in the same units
it's also possible that they're just
sticking what with what's been done in
the past you know it's one of those
things sometimes
you start quantifying something a
certain way it becomes just the standard
traditional way to do it and you
continue with that you keep going on
with it
another thing uh you know another reason
that it might be so popular to scale
protein to total body mass
is that it is the simplest and
the most straightforward way um you know
that you could do it and it gives you an
opportunity
to make sure that large people are
getting more protein recommendations or
higher protein recommendations than
smaller people
without having to do a whole bunch of
body composition testing and things like
that you can say okay this gives more
protein to bigger people who have more
fat-free tissues that are doing you know
protein turnover on a daily basis so
it's kind of the easiest and most
straightforward way to give more protein
to bigger people who presumably have
more lean tissues that are turning over
proteins on a regular basis
so
a question you know the inverse you know
that's kind of discussing why you would
scale to body mass but another question
is why would you scale to something else
and i kind of alluded to the fact that
our lean soft tissues are making a huge
day-to-day contribution to our actual
protein turnover um and i think it's
difficult to argue that
you know for example someone who has
maybe
a hundred pounds of additional kind of
extra adipose tissue it's it's a bit a
bit challenging to argue that that is
making a huge upward impact on their
day-to-day protein needs just having you
know additional adipose tissue around
and so there is some precedent for
scaling things to fat-free mass because
it's a little bit more
it's a little bit more
generalizable to different body
composition situations different levels
of adipose tissue so there's a study by
dickerson and colleagues in 2017
and they were talking about protein
recommendations for people with obesity
who are in a caloric deficit
and i noticed that in this paper they
continuously scaled protein not to body
weight but to ideal body weight um which
you know terminology there i don't know
about it but you know it's basically
just saying like okay if we
assumed that you had lost enough of your
fat free mass to get enough of your
adipose tissue your fat mass to get down
into i forget what cutoff they use but
it's probably bmi based you know like if
we assumed you had a bmi of x here's
what your body weight would be you know
i i think that basically there i forget
exactly how they calculated ideal weight
uh but but they were scaling to this
ideal body weight metric which is really
a roundabout way in my opinion of
scaling to fat free mass it's kind of
saying okay what is the body weight that
we're kind of planning for here without
a given amount of excess adipose tissue
so
uh another interesting paper that you
actually reviewed in mass a couple years
back was by malawani and colleagues from
2018
and uh they were looking at uh you know
basically identifying optimal protein
intakes and in a sample of well-trained
women
they mentioned that uh you know it was
pretty good to increase protein intakes
uh in terms of net protein balance
getting up to about
1.53 grams per kilogram per day i
believe
and so then they kind of looked at the
top of their 95 confidence interval and
it was
1.85 grams per kilogram per day and
those are scaled to
um
to total body total body mass
um and so
your take away in your mass article was
basically that um
if you look at uh these these
recommendations scale to total body mass
protein needs might be a little bit
lower in women compared to men but if
you scaled to fat free mass the
recommendations are virtually identical
and obviously there are
several differences physiologically
between biological male biological
female
but uh of course in this instance one of
the things that would differ is the fact
that at a given body weight
a resistant trained man is likely to
have more fat free mass than a
resistance trained woman and also likely
to have a lower body fat percentage than
a resistance trained woman so
this could indicate that there might be
some subtle sex differences but it also
might indicate that scaling to fat free
mass simply does a slightly better job
than scaling to total body weight
so that that's open to interpretation to
some extent but overall
you know i think when you look into this
question there's unfortunately not too
much direct evidence that really gets at
the question effectively
it seems like things work reasonably
well when you scale protein
recommendations to just total body
weight um
uh and i think
the there are practical challenges of
using a flat protein recommendation uh
one of the practical challenges that
comes to mind if you say i'm going to
give everyone the same recommendation
i'm not going to scale to total body
mass
or to fat free mass
one of the challenges is with a flat
protein dose this puts more constraints
on the diet of a smaller person
especially if you're looking at a low
calorie diet for weight reduction uh if
if you're basically
saying that the amount of protein needed
to optimize hypertrophy in a larger
person
if you're taking that protein dose and
giving the same recommendation to a very
small person with lower fat free mass
it's very likely that they're going to
be on a much lower calorie diet and it's
going to be very hard to work in enough
fat and carbohydrate to make that diet
adequately nutritious and palatable and
enjoyable and practical to implement so
i think there are some practical
constraints that make it a bit
challenging to do a high flat dose for
protein recommendations so it kind of
shifts you into a series of
recommendations where if you're going to
go the approach with
a flat protein amount for all people
you probably ought to be airing on the
lower side um just to make sure that
you're not going to be putting people in
too much of a bind with low calorie
diets
but i think that
there's enough evidence to suggest in my
opinion looking at
you know what seems to work for people
in these applied studies scaling to
total body mass seems to work pretty
well but then you get into other
practical constraints when you're on the
extremes of the body fat percentage
spectrum right so when you're talking
about uh people who have a pretty
substantial amount of excess adipose
tissue sometimes the the protein
recommendations just get really out of
hand really really high protein to the
point where you look at it and it just
even just like a quick
gut feeling you look at it you're like
that is so much protein like i'm really
skeptical that this person needs that
much protein to optimize their you know
uh hypertrophy or fat-free mass
retention when dieting you know things
of that nature
um so i think that intuitively you do
kind of reach that point where you can
tell on the extremes of the body comp
spectrum you're like it just doesn't
really seem like scaling to body weight
is really appropriate here and in those
scenarios i think it becomes apparent
that
my my inclination is to to scale things
to fat free mass rather than total body
weight
and again i i can't really give you a
single study that shows this is
unequivocally why that's the best way to
do it but i'm i'm not particularly
convinced by the study we talked about
at the beginning by mcnaughton and
colleagues i just don't think that gives
us enough to drive you know total daily
protein recommendations i think it's too
far removed when we look at muscle
protein synthesis after a single meal
and i i think that generally speaking
scaling to body weight seems to do fine
in the longitudinal trials where that's
how they dose protein uh but i think
when you look at the mechanistic reasons
that larger people probably ought to
need more protein and then you look at
the practical considerations i think
when you really dig into it it seems
most intuitive to me to scale
recommendations to fat free mass and
ultimately that's that's why we do it
that way in macro factor so
it's a good question and you'll probably
notice that i i don't just like give a
very specific clear answer and say
here's the exact study that shows it and
it's because you really have to piece it
together here and focus on
piecing together research that is you
know there's some longitudinal studies
there are some
kind of mechanistic theoretical
considerations to keep in mind there are
practical considerations to keep in mind
but a study that simply
as far as i'm aware has not been done is
the one where they say
this is a longitudinal study where we
show conclusively
that scaling to body weight is better
than a flat recommendation across the
board and also scaling to fat free mass
is even better than scaling the total
body weight yeah uh it would take quite
a study to do that like it would be
quite an undertaking but um yeah that
that is my perspective on the question
at hand yeah i'm uh
i i would say i'm very sympathetic to
the perspective that
uh maybe scaling to total body mass
isn't the best way to do it um largely
just from coming from the training side
of things where for
decades when you were talking about like
uh
uh quantifying training dose like volume
load was the only thing used or like the
thing
al almost exclusively used um where it's
just like yeah we're going to do sets
times weight times load and and that's
what we're going to use to normalize
things and
seems to work in the literature so
that's what we're gonna go with um but
then you look at the literature and it's
like well this is this is the only thing
you use like you haven't tested
alternatives and then
what really broke the floodgates open
was when people started doing more low
load training research where you know
you're normalizing the number of sets
people are performing but total volume
load is much higher with low load
training but you're still getting pretty
similar hypertrophy responses
and that
kind of got people thinking like uh
maybe maybe sets is both simpler and
better like it seems to be more
predictive of hypertrophy than total
volume load is
as you mentioned there there hasn't been
an ideal study in the nutrition world to
see if a similar dynamic could be in
play with protein um and so i'm
sympathetic to
the argument that it might be um but
yeah we we would just need
uh some some pretty audacious studies to
uh to to really dig into that
yeah and it's possible that maybe
there's something even better than
you know even if we assume that
scaling to body weight is better than a
flat dose and we assume that scaling to
fat free mass is better than scaling to
total body weight even if we assume all
that to be true it's possible that there
could be something even better
than that because
uh i would expect that
muscle and non-muscle fat-free tissues
have a different impact on protein needs
you know the other
on one hand you're thinking about the
actual turnover of skeletal muscle
proteins and how if you know if you grow
bigger and bigger with more hypertrophy
maybe that factors into it you also have
to think about uh splenic extraction
like extraction of gut tissues that are
you know taking some of that protein uh
for their own use before it you know
makes it out uh and ultimately makes it
to skeletal muscle tissues um
you know there's a lot to be considered
there so it's very possible that
even scaling to fat free mass as if it's
just a singular thing
could be uh you know an over
simplification so you could get down
into details as granular as you wish in
terms of kind of theorizing and
mechanistic speculation but for me
uh i think that recommendations
currently do pretty well
if you're using total body weight over
kind of the the middle portion of the
range of body body fat percentage values
um and but the the nice thing about fat
free mass recommendations uh you know
scaling to fat free mass is that you can
generalize and extrapolate that even
into the extremes of uh
very far below average body fat levels
and very far above average body fat
levels so for my use
that comes in handy for me personally
makes sense to me uh cool you got a
question you want to answer here yeah so
a question from jamie fay how much can
muscle fiber type vary between
individuals and what are the factors
that determine what type or types uh
eg genetics hormones exercise history
etc how do those things influence your
fiber types
i know that it's all on a spectrum but i
want to optimize my training by
selecting appropriate rep ranges for
individual muscles according to their
dominant fiber type
is there a way to determine whether
you're fast or slow twitch dominant in a
muscle or muscle group i've read the
testing your eighty percent
that testing your eighty percent one rep
max load for reps uh versus your one rep
max can provide insight uh but how
reliable is such a metric
so yeah uh that's a good question and
there's a lot going on there and it
seems like there's um
a reasonable number of assumptions
underpinning this question so uh yeah
let's let's dig into it so first off uh
the first question was basically
um you know how much
can fiber types vary between muscles and
between individuals um
most of the
muscles that you'd kind of be focusing
on training at the gym
on average have approximately a 50 50
split of type 1 and type 2 fibers um
really the biggest exception to that is
the soleus
the calf muscle under your gastroc for
most people that's closer to like 80
percent slow twitch 20 fast twitch uh
but kind of just looking at population
averages most muscles are somewhere in
the vicinity of 50 50 with uh so-called
fast twitch dominant athletes maybe
being closer to 70 30 and so-called slow
twitch dominant athletes being closer to
uh 30-70
so yeah it can vary quite a bit between
individuals and
i think it's it's theoretically possible
that it could vary quite a bit between
muscles within an individual although
uh citations looking at that in
particular aren't immediately coming to
mind um
and and this question also asks like
what is this influenced by is it
influenced by genetics hormones training
history etc um and yeah it is probably
influenced by all of those things when
you uh
when you see pretty large differences
between individuals um you can you can
presume that there is probably a genetic
component there so someone who
has say 70 percent fast twitch dominant
quads uh their genetic profile is
probably different from someone who has
70 slow twitch dominant quads um
although i don't think like a full
genetic accounting for
how you get to those fiber type
differences has fully been done
so i think just looking at the
variability that exists we can
we can surmise that there is probably a
genetic component but that that piece of
it isn't fully understood yet
and there is probably a hormonal
component as well um
so sex hormones likely influence fiber
type distributions at least to some
extent
on average
females have a slightly higher
proportion of type 1 slow twitch fibers
than males and vice versa for type 2
fibers um
i think that people often overstate the
magnitude of the difference uh we're
talking about like
maybe a five ten percent difference so
kind of
as a population average maybe males have
55 percent fast twitch 45 slow twitch
fibers and for women it's like 55 slow
twitch 45 fast twitch fibers which
ultimately and functionally not a
particularly large difference so you
probably don't need to
be too concerned about that or or
proactively account for it when
designing training programs for male and
female athletes but
that is a difference that does exist
and likely has a
and likely has a hormonal contribution
to it
and also training can affect fiber types
so
up to this point when answering the
question the this is this is something
that uh i'm almost positive i've talked
about on the podcast before but
up to this point when answering this
question i've just referred to fast
twitch type 2 fibers slow twitch type 1
fibers
but fiber types themselves exist on a
spectrum
where
for
it for an untrained person
typically you have
a pool of pure type one fibers where
if you
took a biopsy you isolated the fibers
and you basically look to look to see
the different protein expression within
the fibers all of the myosin heavy chain
heads would be type one so you have a
pool of type one fibers you have a pool
of uh type 2a fibers where you know same
thing you do a biopsy separate the
fibers you're going to have some
proportion of fibers where all of the
myosin heavy chains are type 2a
and then you typically have some hybrid
fibers as well so though there there's a
pretty
sizable pool of type 1 type 2a hybrids
where
within a single fiber there will be some
type 1 heads and some type 2a heads uh
you'll probably have a pool of type 2a
type 2x hybrids where
the the so-called super fast twitch type
2x fibers you'll have some of those
myosin heavy chain heads and some just
normal fast twitch 2a myosin heavy
chains
and then you can also have hybrids with
all of the fiber types within a single
fiber there will be some type 1 myosin
some type 2a myosin and some type 2x
myosin
and then as you train
basically those hybrid fibers tend to
differentiate so if you do a lot of
endurance training um
the type 1 type 2a hybrids most of them
will lose their type 2a myosin and
become and express themselves more as
just pure type 1 fibers
and the type 2a type 2x hybrids they'll
lose their 2x myosin heavy chains and
just become pure type 2a fibers
with resistance training
the type 1 type 2a hybrids go the
opposite direction they tend to
differentiate to become pure type 2a
fibers or at least express themselves as
such
but the 2a 2x hybrids
still just lose their their 2x myosin
heavy chains they they also tend to
become pure type 2a fibers and so that's
actually one of the signatures of of
training so untrained people you tend to
see a relatively large pool of hybrid
fibers uh i mean i don't want to
overstate it like 20 30 percent of your
your fibers tend to be hybrids uh for
untrained people and then if you take a
biopsy of a trained athlete no matter
what type of training they're doing you
find very few hybrids and most of the
fibers you see are pure type 1 or pure
type 2a so that differentiation happens
with training and it does seem to be
influenced by
the type of training you do so
if you did a lot of heavy strength power
training uh those hybrids would shift
more in the 2a direction uh and if you
stopped doing any of that resistance
training and just endurance training uh
the the the hybrids would probably shift
and start being more type one ish um so
yeah that's not going to make just a
completely night and day difference
taking you from like 80 fast twitch to
80 slow twitch but it it can shift on
the margins uh to to an extent
that might have some some actual
functional implications
um
so yeah all of those things mentioned in
the question uh can and do uh influence
fiber type to some extent so now when
the rubber meets the road uh how can you
know what uh what predominant fiber
types you have and much more importantly
does it actually matter
um
at least in so far as you know you're
trying to optimize strength gains you're
trying to optimize muscle growth
will training based on your fiber type
actually result in net better training
outcomes
so starting with
basically fiber typing yourself can you
figure out uh if you're predominantly
fast twitch or slow twitch or if a
particular muscle group is predominantly
fast twitch or slow twitch and
unfortunately the answer to that
question is no there have been
three studies i believe that have looked
at this
um
using
so two of them used basically what was
asked about in the question like kind of
uh
differentiating based on performance in
a rep max test so the the popular
approach to this
was popularized by charles poliquin uh
may he rest in peace where basically you
you take a lift um
and you put either 80 or 70 of your one
rep max on the bar uh and with the 80
version you do reps to failure so you
know let's say you squat 400 pounds you
put 320 pounds on the bar you do a set
to failure if you get
about eight reps i i think seven to nine
reps uh you would be classified as
someone who's not fast twitch or slow
twitch dominant
if you get six or fewer reps you would
be classified as a fast twitch dominant
athlete at least for the muscles
involved in the squat
and if you get 10 or more reps in that
set you would be classified as a slow
twitch dominant squatter
for the 70 version basically the cutoff
is 12. so
uh
11 to 13 reps you would be intermediate
if you got 14 or more you'd be slow
twitch if you got
10 or fewer you'd be fast twitch so so
like that's how those tests work um
there have been two studies that use
some variation on that and they find
that basically it's a very poor
predictor of fiber types like if you um
if you have someone do those tests and
then actually like biopsy their quads do
the fiber types in their quads actually
correlate with how they do on those
tests uh
technically yes there is some amount of
correlation there
but not to a degree where it becomes
predictive enough to be useful
and so
yeah you can't use functional tests like
that to estimate it well there was
another study
where
they used a combination of i believe a
max power test on a dynamometer and then
looking at the rate at which power
output decreased during repeated reps on
a dynamometer and that did seem to be
predictive to some degree but you know
unless you have access to a research
grade dynamometer you can't really do
that test on yourself
and that style of testing hasn't been
validated for just kind of like normal
gym equipment
um
so yeah really the only ways you can
actually know what your fiber types are
the gold standard you get a biopsy
someone spends entirely too much time to
actually like count which fibers pick up
stains or you know you do like an actual
uh pcr test to look at the mice and
heavy chains in each fiber
that's the gold standard
um
which you know obviously you can't do at
home and then there's another
like proxy test that you see in research
sometimes where they use proton magnetic
resonance spectroscopy
to look at the relative carnosine
content in muscles so muscles with a
higher carnosine content tend to have a
greater relative proportion of type 2
fibers
so that's very cool because it's a
non-invasive test you don't have to
take a biopsy in order to run that test
but also
i assume you don't have a proton
magnetic resonance spectroscoper in your
in your house or at your local gym so
that's also not really a test you can do
on yourself and outside of having access
to that equipment there really isn't a
reliable way to know what your
predominant fiber type is or what the
predominant fiber type of a particular
muscle is uh so that may sound bad it's
like oh no i can't have access to this
information how am i going to optimize
my training for the fiber types i have
and here's the good news you don't you
don't need to uh
based on the research we have doesn't
seem to matter very much
there's this popular idea that dates
back decades and decades that
if you train
uh in a manner that seems to lean into
the physiological characteristics of a
particular fiber type you will
predominantly stress that particular
fiber type leading to more growth
and maybe larger strength gains as well
so
type 1 fibers are more endurant they're
more fatigue resistant
so the idea being if you do
really high rep training that's going to
predominantly stress your type 1 fibers
leading to more type 1 fiber growth and
vice versa type 2 fibers they're more
powerful
they don't actually seem to be that much
stronger that's a common misconception
when you scale for fiber size maximal
contractile force is either the same in
type 1 and type 2 fibers are only very
slightly higher in type 2 fibers
whatever but they are definitely more
powerful they have a greater shortening
velocity so the idea being if you do
heavy training or power training uh
that's going to predominantly stress
your type 2 fibers leading to more type
2 growth
and some people even push it farther and
say like oh well type 2 fibers seem to
be more prone to hypertrophy than type 1
fibers are so like you really need to
lean into power based training in order
to fully grow your type 2 fibers and and
that's the the ticket to huge gains um
anyways best i can tell uh those those
recommendations
were
pulled
from someone's [ __ ] and weren't
actually based on any actual evidence um
studies where people are exposed to
different styles of training biopsies
are taken and you actually look to see
like hey does this style of training
affect fiber type
specific type 1 and type 2 fiber growth
better or worse than this other style of
training those studies have come around
really within like the last decade or so
for the most part and for
the vast majority of them find it
doesn't really matter um there are
there is one
one kind of outlier study
you can point to i believe
it was
the high load low load study by
schweinke in 2012. should have put this
in the notes i'm pretty sure that's the
study i have in mind though
but that study did find
way way more type 2 fiber growth with
heavier training than lighter training
and so like that is a study people
sometimes point to uh but best i can
tell the overall findings of that study
have never been replicated so that was
that is the one study where high load
like 8rm training
led to way more growth than low load 20
rm training
that's the only study that's ever found
that um
every other study i've seen where people
take
loads above about thirty percent of one
rm do the same number of sets to failure
tend to find similar overall hypertrophy
between kind of heavier or moderate load
training and low load training uh that's
the one study that didn't and that's
also the one study where there did maybe
seem to be a fiber type specific growth
response
so until more studies
have overall results that are similar to
that study i personally don't put too
much stock in it all of the other
research in the area tends to suggest
low load training it's good for growing
your type 1 fibers also good for growing
your type 2 fibers heavier training good
for growing your type 2 fibers also good
for growing your type 1 fibers so
yeah it doesn't really seem like you
need to train in
a specific way to optimize type 1 versus
type 2 fiber growth uh so yeah you it
you can't really figure out your fiber
type breakdown with with non-invasive
tests and without expensive lab
equipment
but the good news is that you don't need
to um
you just train and both of your both of
your fiber types seem to grow just fine
good stuff that's a relief less stuff to
worry about yes sir um all right i'm
gonna go quick with one here uh in the
interest of time i got a question i've
got a few people who reached out to me
about a new study on artificial
sweeteners
um
and uh so this study was called
artificial sweeteners and cancer risk
results from the nutrinet sante
population based cohort study
um and and so this uh this study came
out a lot of headlines
resulted from it
kind of just
re
just kind of fanning the flames on the
general concerns of artificial
sweeteners potentially increasing cancer
risk so
um
it's been an interesting history with
artificial sweeteners
and you know they each are distinct
compounds so you can't necessarily paint
with too broad a brush when you discuss
their research but back in the day there
were some rodent studies suggesting i
don't know aspartame looks kind of scary
might cause some cancer
uh very thorough review of that data
among
experts in the area suggested yeah we
don't think that these rodent studies
are generalizable and robust therefore
you see that aspartame
largely embraced across the world as a
safe food ingredient
but you know there are a lot of these
studies that kind of revisit the topic
and look at you know within certain
cohorts um you know
what what kind of relationships do we
see here between artificial sweetener
intake and cancer risk so uh with this
one um
you know the the general takeaway was
that uh you know artificial sweeteners
increased uh cancer incidents within
this cohort
um
that was uh particularly true of
aspartame and also
uh ace k um
acid sulfame potassium
uh
not
not much of a relationship for sucralose
oddly enough hell yeah um but anyway a
lot of people have sent this study to me
um
a little bit concerned and rightfully so
about the headlines but when you dig
beneath the service a little bit uh it
doesn't look quite as scary as some of
the uh some of the headlines would lead
you to believe
um and i i i think that people are just
trying to write interesting articles
that reflect the paper i'm not saying
that people are trying to
blow it out of proportion intentionally
but
with a paper like this one of the first
places i look uh is just the the raw
incident rates in these different groups
uh and i'm not saying that we should
ignore all other models and only look at
raw incidence rates or anything like
that but i do think they're informative
for just kind of setting like okay what
are we seeing here just in a very broad
kind of overview
so we're talking about the cancer
incidence rate in these three different
groups there were non-consumers of
artificial sweeteners there were low
consumers and there were high consumers
so the raw incidence rates for getting
some type of cancer during this
observation period were it was 3.1
percent for non-consumers it was 3.9
percent for low consumers and 3.2
percent approximately for high consumers
so that alone you know kind of sets our
frame of reference for this the
discussion across this entire spectrum
of intakes we're talking about 3.1 to
3.9 percent as the incidence rates
and also in the unadjusted models
completely raw numbers that we're seeing
here
we see that the low consumer incidence
rate was actually a little bit higher
than the high consumer so
obviously you know you don't want to get
too
you don't want to put too much stock
into that until you do adjusted models
with covariates and things like that but
just a quick survey of these numbers you
would not look at that and say if you
consume a lot of artificial sweeteners
you are totally screwed
and i also think it's uh
it's useful here just to
make explicit the difference between
relative and absolute risk because the
the headline that i've been seeing all
over the place and i mean the the
headline implied by
just the abstract of the paper
is that for
for a particular given increase in
artificial sweetener consumption uh risk
of cancer goes up by approximately 20 i
think it was like 18 or something like
that yeah um
which you know seems like kind of a big
scary number but based on the
range of data we're looking at it's it's
in terms of absolute risk it's 3.1 on
the low end 3.9 on the high end
so you know going from
three percent to four percent risk
that's a 33 increase also one percent
increase depending on on how you look at
it uh in terms of relative or absolute
terms so that's always something you
need to keep in mind when we're having
discussions about things like this
yeah um so
that's one of the reasons that i'm not
super concerned about this finding is
just kind of using those numbers to
kind of set our frame of reference here
um but digging deeper um just a few
things that i would bring up um i don't
think that we have
really good we i don't think we have a
really clear
kind of causal pathway drawn out with
all the mechanisms filled in
for how
ace k would cause cancer and for how
aspartame would cause cancer and we
would need those two to be drawn out
separately because we're talking about
completely different compounds with
completely different chemical structures
so
just the idea of saying like well
artificial sweeteners they're not
natural therefore they give you cancer
like that's not good enough for a
mechanism and i think there's a lot more
work to be done if we're going to assume
that this association observed here is
causal there's a lot more work that
needs to be done to actually figure out
the mechanistic underpinnings for why
that would be for how these would
actually cause cancer
but more importantly you know the first
thing you want to look at with this type
of study
is are these findings robust and are
they generalizable because what we want
to see is this finding
our can we look at this finding in this
group of people and extrapolate it out
into other groups of people like
is this something that people outside of
this cohort
should be concerned about because it
truly does relate to them and when i was
kind of pondering that question i found
one thing that was really fascinating
was this finding doesn't even
necessarily generalize within this
cohort um and i mean that you could
argue against that statement by kind of
getting into the details but um within
this cohort
just determining you know if there's a
link between artificial sweeteners and
cancer
is really complicated because there was
a previous study from this same cohort
that was like a couple years ago
that found that artificially
it found that the consumption of sugary
drinks was significantly associated with
overall cancer risk but it found that
artificially sweetened beverages were
not associated with cancer and so the
distinction is that in this particular
paper this newer one they were looking
at total consumption of artificial
sweeteners not just looking at
artificially sweetened beverages
and so they were looking at for example
adding in like table top sweeteners that
were added to foods and things like that
so
without question artificially sweetened
beverages are a huge contributor to
total intake of artificial sweeteners
but to me i find it very very surprising
that within a cohort
you know there would be a truly
causative link between artificial
sweetener intake but not intake of
artificially sweetened beverages
you know
so i i think i made a face when you
when you first mentioned that because i
was i was just like
where else are people getting a ton of
artificial sweeteners in their diet such
that
you don't see this association with
beverages but you do with total
artificial sweetener consumption um
like
i do i was having a hard time coming up
with where do
the where would the rest of the
non-beverage artificial sweeteners come
from and the only things that
immediately came to mind and you know
this is me on the spot um
i might be overlooking something obvious
but
i don't know man like
[ __ ] health foods and supplements
like that that's about all i can come up
with
um
yeah and like
i don't know uh
i wouldn't i wouldn't be stunned if like
maybe if
those types of products are
like let's just say that this
relationship is real and that it is
causal and that something's driving it
um
like one of the things we talk about on
this podcast from time to time is just
like a lot of supplement manufacturers
have like kind of kind of dodgy sourcing
or manufacturing practices like uh there
was there was a whole issue
with dangerous levels of heavy metal
contamination and protein supplements a
few years back like
i don't know man if it's not the
beverages and it's like maybe some of
that other stuff
might it might not even be the
artificial sweeteners doing it like even
well i guess i just said assuming it is
causal so i just shot myself in the foot
but you you get what i'm saying here
like
if it's food products with artificial
sweeteners
it's
that would that leads my brain down a
road of
uh food products that i already have
negative associations with so
i don't know so
they they're uh they've got a figure
that indicates about 53
percent
of the
artificial sweeteners
were coming from soft drinks with no
added sugar so your kind of typical diet
beverage
29 was coming from tabletop sweeteners
which seems like a ton to me but there
you go
uh this is this might be what surprises
you here almost eight percent was coming
from yogurt and cottage cheese products
that had artificial sweeteners i can see
that i can um
another four percent from soft drinks
that had both added sugar and artificial
sweeteners
uh fruit-based beverages and purees
about a percent and a half and then
other was like four percent so they did
go into detail about where these
sweeteners were coming from but again i
just really struggle with the robustness
and the generalizability of a finding
where even within this cohort you know
because the the place that most people
go with this when they see this headline
is oh [ __ ]
i need to stop having diet soda and i
guess i'll switch to like regular
sugared beverages like maybe fruit juice
or maybe a full sugar soda whatever the
case may be but even within this cohort
artificially sweet artificial
artificially sweetened beverages were
not associated with cancer risk but
sugar sweetened beverages were and even
100 fruit juice was significantly
associated with cancer within this
cohort
and so uh
if the utility of this is to basically
find an alternative beverage
for your uh you know artificially
sweetened beverage
it doesn't leave a lot on the table
really because if you're going for fruit
juice
if you're going for a full sugar
beverage based on this study it wouldn't
necessarily indicate that that's a
trade-off that would be indicated
and i thought one other thing that kind
of
relates to that as i was going through
this i was thinking okay so
what exactly
is the alternative here because usually
when people talk about artificial
sweeteners it's about the trade-off
between having something that's
artificially sweetened versus something
that is sweetened with sugar or some
other kind of caboric sweetener like
honey or something like that
uh
so
what they did here in this study was
they broke it down into like a grid with
six categories so it was like you're
either eating above the sugar
recommendation
or or you're below it so high sugar
intake or low
and then also you had no artificial
sweeteners
or low artificial sweetener intake or
high so you've got for artificial
sweeteners three categories none low or
high and then for sugar you're above the
recommendation or you're below
so
the hierarchy that they kind of set up
in one of the supplementary figures was
the best case scenario for cancer risk
based on the this cohort these findings
was low sugar intake and no artificial
sweeteners
um fair enough not very fun for your
taste buds uh then they've got this kind
of next best thing which uh was you know
slightly elevated in terms of cancer
risk again within this cohort
and it was you know if you had low sugar
intake and low artificial sweetener
intake if you had low sugar intake and
high artificial sweetener intake or if
you had high sugar intake and no
artificial sweetener intake all three of
those were pretty much equivalent in
terms of the uh cancer incidence you
know that the hazard ratio calculated
the worst case scenario was was two
categories or two kind of combinations
of these categories
high sugar with low artificial sweetener
intake or high sugar
with high artificial sweetener intake so
it would seem for some reason
that the you know if we're assuming that
there you know really is a deleterious
impact here of artificial sweeteners it
seemed to be most pronounced in the
people who had high sugar intakes but
when you look at the people who had
really
who were below the daily recommendation
for sugar
it really wasn't so bad you know it was
this kind of middle of the road kind of
pack where there was all these different
combinations of sugar and artificial
sweeteners that
weren't as good as the
low sugar no sweetener group
but still it wasn't getting under those
really high elevations that were
observed in people who are eating a lot
of sugar in combination with a lot of
artificial sweeteners um the the low or
the high artificial sweetener group so
in a nutshell uh you might be looking at
these findings and being like man these
seem kind of contradictory kind of
counterintuitive there doesn't seem to
be that clear of a dose response
relationship
within the cohort it looks like the way
you define artificial sweetener intake
has a huge impact
like the source of the artificial
sweeteners has a big impact
overall i'm just not really convinced
that these are
these associations reported are truly
robust and generalizable and have a huge
impact on cancer risk so i personally i
look through this paper i don't find it
to be particularly concerning doesn't
mean the researchers did anything wrong
but that is kind of the nature of
nutritional epidemiology if if you put
all of your food related decisions into
a singular finding from nutritional
epidemiology you would have a very
confusing time trying to put together a
diet that had you know no potentially
deleterious uh
uh outcomes likely uh now you've been
making several frowny faces it looks
like your gears are turning yeah so i'll
i'll admit something uh a lot of the
people who sent this study to you
were probably people who originally sent
this study to me and they said what's
your take on this and i said i i don't
have one this this is in my area uh
message eric instead he's the nutrition
guy so i'm i'm just now looking at some
of the stuff in here
i just want to know more about the
french food supply because i feel like
virtually a hundred percent of americans
consume at least some amount of
artificial sweeteners every day but
apparently they they
based this grouping on 24-hour food
recalls
um
and
like
in excess of 60
of the people in this study said that
they consumed nothing with any
artificial sweeteners in it the previous
day
and like that very well may be correct i
have no idea what the artificial
sweetener game in france is like
but
damn that's a that's a much higher
number than than i would have
anticipated so anyway that doesn't uh
that doesn't influence
the interpretation of the study at all
um
but i found that bit surprising
it is surprising yeah also
have there been any people talking about
how
this study
even even if the results are accurate uh
and maybe there is a causal link uh
although to be clear i'm not sold on it
have there been people talking about how
this uh
is predominantly
in female subjects
no so just looking at this like 80 of
the subjects were women um and i'm
certainly not trying to say that cancer
risk in women is unimportant uh
but you know my
social media feed
i've been seeing a lot of dudes posting
about this um
and i just don't know how concerned they
need to be because
like if there were to be like a sex
interaction i don't know if there were
enough males in this sample to really
tell much about that yeah but yeah the
the biggest thing that jumped out at me
is that uh
apparently like
60 plus percent of the people in this
study had consumed no artificial
sweeteners the previous day and that
just blew my mind i thought uh i thought
everyone was was just out there
with at least some amount of artificial
sweeteners in their diet
so it says here uh
caution should be taken before
extrapolating to the whole adult french
population
uh participants were more likely to be
women to have higher educational and
socio-professional levels and to have
health-conscious behaviors
and to be older on average uh they they
said that those might contribute to the
fact that uh artificial artificial
sweetener intake levels were lower than
reported uh in the in the broader french
population gotcha so um you know
i think um one of the challenging things
with papers like this is
i think that the research researchers
did a very nice job with it
uh and there
there is room for an interpretation in
which you say i think that these are
very competent researchers who did a
nice job carrying out the tasks that
they set out to carry out but i don't
find the the actual finding itself to be
particularly frightening
nor am i convinced that there is a
causal relationship we're seeing here
that will generalize uh outside of this
cohort and as we see
you know like like i said one of the
first things that i think about when i
whenever i hear
um
a study about artificial sweeteners is
all the people who
drink a full sugar soda and say ah i
told you switching over to diet was
pretty bad and so like the first thing i
go is like well
what what actually would happen if based
on this
cohort we changed all of our full sugar
beverages over to diet beverages that
had artificial sweeteners uh and like i
said based on the previous publication
from this cohort itself it would suggest
that
you know cancer
uh risk was elevated for full sugar
beverages but not for artificially
sweetened beverages so
at the very least uh the the conclusion
that's hard to argue with is the fact
that there's a lot more going on here
than just a very straightforward
strong robust causative relationship by
which
choosing any artificially sweetened uh
food or drink product is going to be a
really regrettable choice um the the
numbers just don't really seem to bear
that out yeah
all right do you want to do one more
uh yeah sure
um how what what time are we at i'm just
so far over uh
hour and 20.
i'm fine saving them uh okay cool cool
let's do uh let's do the nitrate one
we'll collaborate on that one and then
i'll play us out so uh we did get a
question this is a question we get a lot
uh and actually greg you found this one
from
instaterra
and uh i figure we'll team up on this
because you're you're into food science
which is relevant here and then uh the
questions about nitrate which is a topic
one of the topics of my dissertation
research so the question was
what are our thoughts on the health
impact of nitrates outside of
performance you know we've talked about
the performance benefits but this is
outside of performance
the question continues seems like there
is a popular consensus that leafy green
nitrates are healthy but nitrates in
meat are linked with cancer through a
nitrate to nitrite to nitrosamine
conversion in the gut is there any good
evidence out there
so there's a really nice review paper by
uh nathan bryan
and the the title is inorganic nitrite
and nitrate evidence to support
consideration as dietary nutrients and
nathan brian has done a lot of research
in the night the nitrate space um i've
even seen him go so far as to argue it
should be considered a vitamin um you
know so so he's he's done a lot of
really cool nitrate research but they
have a nice little figure where they
talk about the potential benefits which
are cardiovascular in nature
weighed against the potential risks so
on the benefit side
you've got lower blood pressure improved
vascular function lower inflammation
improved exercise capacity improved
mitochondrial function lower
triglycerides less heart attacks less
strokes and these are cardio
cardiovascular benefits presumably of
consuming a diet rich in you know a lot
of plant-based nitrate sources
and then this is all balanced against
the kind of singular risk that you hear
about which is the potential formation
of n-nitrosamines which are uh presumed
to be uh carcinogenic that you know
there's there is research that these
compounds can be carcinogenic but the
relationship between dietary nitrate
and cancer is is really complicated and
really messy
so intuitively one might assume that
because these nitrosamines can be
carcinogenic and they can be derived
from nitrate the idea would be that
regardless of nitrate source you know a
high nitrate diet is likely to increase
cancer risk
but the research doesn't really bear
that out and there's actually an
interesting study by song and colleagues
where they found that high nitrate
intake was actually associated with
lower risk of gastric cancer which the
whole nitrosamine idea theoretically
would have a particularly
high degree of relevance to gastric
cancers specifically so nitrate in this
study was actually associated with
reduced risk of gastric cancer but the
consumption of nitrites so not nitrates
but nitrites and
ndma which is a nitrosamine did seem to
be risk factors for cancer within this
particular study um
but what's really fascinating when you
dig into some of the epidemiological
evidence assessing this question uh it
looks like uh you're really not going to
get any pushback if you say
plant-derived nitrate sources the fruits
and vegetables that are high in nitrate
are unequivocally healthful additions to
the diet
you're not going to get any pushback
the the place where there is some really
interesting debate is whether or not
uh
processed meats
uh with with high nitrate and nitrite
content whether or not those might be
carcinogenic or risk factors for gastric
cancer some research would suggest
suggest yes some would suggest a fairly
neutral effect and so the question is
about uh you know what is the context of
the ingestion of of those particular
nitrate and nitrite products
and when you look at the epidemiological
evidence and some of the mechanistic
evidence it would suggest that
when you're consuming nitrate in
combination with fiber and vitamin c and
other antioxidants
it doesn't seem very likely that you're
going to get a tremendous amount of
nitrosamine formation
and certainly it doesn't seem like these
different plant-based nitrate sources
that contain
fiber and plenty of antioxidants they
simply don't seem to be increasing the
risk of gastric cancers to an
appreciable degree
the question is and this is more getting
into the food science component
how might that differ when instead of
talking about raw spinach
you know how does that differ when we're
talking about
a processed meat product with a ton of
nitrite content that is cooked at a
really high heat and consumed in the
absence of fiber yeah so i'm glad you
asked uh so the
so what's going on with with vegetables
that you're getting nitrate or nitrite
from uh versus meat it's a completely
different story
so
when people talk about
nitrates and meat there's not actually
that much nitrate left in the meat
so
if you're using pink curing salt
generally
i think what's most accessible to
consumers is potassium nitrate i think
on an industrial scale they generally
use sodium nitrite uh but they
accomplish the same basic purpose you
you make a brine with them you soak the
meat in it or you just kind of let them
soak into the meat directly
and the the whole purpose of those
historically what people thought they
did
is that they would help preserve the
meat
and present the grow or prevent the
growth of uh the the i think bacteria
maybe mold i think it's a bacteria uh
whatever the botulinum toxin basically
you're trying to avoid botulism and they
thought that treating meats with nitrate
would help prevent botulism um anyway
turns out that that's not entirely true
it seems to be the salt that you cure
the meat with that helps a lot more
than the nitrates or nitrites but the
nitrates or nitrites add a
characteristic flavor to food that
people often go for um like if you've
ever wondered like hey why does corned
beef brisket taste very different from
just like a smoked brisket it's the
nitrates that they were treated with
that was the main thing um and also they
help preserve color so
if you cure a meat for a long time uh
typically the
the iron in the hemoglobin will oxidize
and the meat will turn kind of brownish
which uh functionally is fine doesn't
really seem to make much of a difference
uh in terms of taste or quality of the
product
but it looks bad like it it looks like
the meat is rotting consumers don't like
that
and so
what the nitrates or nitrites are
actually doing is they they get into the
meat and then the nitrates or nitrites
themselves break down
and one of the end products is our old
friend uh nitric oxide ol no
which has an affinity for the heme group
in hemoglobin yeah and hemoglobin or
myoglobin um and so basically it it just
hooks on to that
exposed part of the iron that can accept
something else typically oxygen when
you're alive
and so it
hooks on there and it prevents the iron
from oxidizing which keeps the cured
meat pink
which is a more attractive color to
people stops it from turning brown
um
and still like from like an industrial
food production perspective even though
we now know it's not actually necessary
to prevent botulism it does speed up the
curing process relative to just salt so
you know a product that maybe would have
taken
a month of curing in just like a salt
solution or a sugar and salt solution
maybe you can get it
shelf stable and ready to rock with
after two weeks if you add some some
nitrate salts into the mix uh but
basically
um that's what it's doing the nitrates
nitrites break down form nitric oxide
and that bonds to the to the uh the heme
group and the hemoglobin and that's what
basically makes it do its stuff so in
the end you don't actually have that
much nitrate or nitrite left in the
product
you just have nitric oxide there bound
to the heme
which in and of itself even if you're
not cooking it at high temperatures
might be problematic so that's called
nitrosyl heme which i don't think this
has been proven but there's some
evidence to suggest that nitrosal heme
itself might be carcinogenic uh and then
also
you have kind of a very broken down in
product in the form of nitric oxide
they're in relatively high quantities
within the meat itself so then when you
expose it to high heat chemical
reactions take place and you can get
pretty
rapid
nitrosamine formation which
i think is
known or even is more strongly suspected
to be carcinogenic um
so yeah basically you just don't have
that same dynamic in play with plants
like you have the the nitrates they're
intact when you're consuming them they
are nitrates they're not nitric oxide
bound to heme um
and so yeah just just all of this [ __ ]
that can happen to make them
carcinogenic isn't really present like
you're consuming them as nitrates
they're being absorbed as nitrates and
you're good to go whereas for cured
meats the nitrate salts break down to
the nitric oxide that is already bound
to the heme group may in and of itself
be carcinogenic we're not totally sure
but it definitely increases the
probability of that nitric oxide hooking
up with other protein compounds to form
nitrosamines um
so yeah the the starting the thing
you're starting with the nitrates very
similar
but
uh what you're actually dealing with by
the time it comes to cook and eat it
it's a it's a very different
situation so that's why
cured meats might be problematic when it
comes to cancer risk but nitrates from
vegetables
don't seem to be and also i'll note
there's a
what i think to be
a very sneaky grift going on in kind of
the natural food community where
uh what you can do if you want to
tell people like oh like yeah you're
buying this cured meat from uh from like
whole foods or something and like we
don't use the nitrate salts like the bad
guys do we use uh nitrates from celery
so it's good for you it's the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] man you extract the
nitrates from anywhere you put it in
meat it's gonna break down to nitric
oxide like if you've cured meat and
there's nitrate uh
in that process the end result of the
meat is the same uh it doesn't matter if
it comes from a factory and people make
nitrate salts and that's what you use or
if you just extract the nitrate straight
from celery the the cured meat product
that you wind up with is the same uh
there's every reason to suspect that
it's going to have similar effects on on
cancer risk uh so yeah if you come
across that in the supermarket it says
oh cured with with uh nitrate from
celery that's a scam
it costs them more to cure meat that way
so they're charging you more for it and
ultimately you don't get anything in
return so uh yeah if you're gonna get
cured meat which like no hate cured meat
is delicious uh just get the cheap stuff
that's made with nitrate salt or better
yet
potentially go for cured meats that
weren't cured with nitrate salts again
you can cure meats just fine with just
salt or a mixture of salt and sugar that
will still cure the meat it might not be
quite as attractive to look at it might
be a little more brownish not quite as
as bright vibrant pink or red
but it should still be perfectly safe to
eat so
um
and honestly
i don't i don't know if meat cured
without nitrates affects cancer risk
like in the epidemiological studies
everything's kind of all lumped together
you know
um
and the vast majority of cured meats
do
cure the meats with nitrates like i
don't know if the relative consumption
of non-nitrate cured meat is a large
enough component of the diet yet to
actually investigate whether that
affects cancer risk but you know it's
it's possible that meat that's just
cured with salt and sugar would have a
similar
impact on cancer risk as just
consuming any other meat product would i
don't know if that's the case or not but
that's at least
a potential thing to keep in mind as as
we're looking at research going forward
um
but yeah long story short cured meat
versus nitrates and plants very
different things and eating vegetables
still seems to be generally pretty good
correct um because of science
all right so
to play us out uh
i obviously went on a vacation which
opened up room for greg to pull the
scheme that he pulled with forming his
union but uh man i went to the outer
banks for a little weekend trip to outer
banks in north carolina
unequivocal enthusiastic travel
recommendation if you ever have a chance
to go um
you may know it from the teen drama
outer banks on television i have no idea
what that's about uh i don't know
what the uh common expectation is that
people have for like what the outer
banks
is like as a place
but man it is such a cool place there's
so much history there so i was at
roanoke island where they had the lost
colony i had never heard of that which
probably says too much about my
education growing up but if you've never
heard of the lost colony over at roanoke
island look it up it was so fascinating
the north carolina coast i learned is
called the graveyard of the atlantic
there were over 2 000 ships that sunk
there since like the mid-1500s and like
i was just walking down the beach and
saw something i was like oh what's that
it was the the steam stack from a sunken
ship from 1862 like so cool so learned
so much about the history of the area
and of course the outer banks is where
the wright brothers uh you know had the
first um the first flight you know the
first airplane heavier than air flying
machine north carolina first in flight
glad we glad we all agree here on this
podcast
exactly a couple strong buckeyes a
couple good ohio guys it was in our
union contract that you have to admit
that north carolina is first in flight
yes that is where the first flight
occurred uh so anyway they've got the
wright brothers museum and if you're
into science i could not recommend that
museum highly enough uh it was so cool
because like you know that achieving
flight obviously was an incredible feat
but i never really took time to think
about what the process would have looked
like
um and so here's a couple of guys
neither of them had a high school
diploma
and they really wanted to fly they own
the bicycle shop and you know they like
messing with things and engineering and
stuff
and for a while they were toiling and
using all the textbook equations uh and
all the coefficients that have been
calculated and at a certain point
they're like dude i don't think these
are right you know they're like i see
the textbook here i just don't think
they're correct and so they basically
threw out the textbooks built a wind
tunnel and recalculated all the [ __ ]
they needed to make it work and they're
like oh yeah those coefficients were all
way off but but we got the right numbers
and i mean that was a really pivotal
part of them making it work um so it's
crazy to see them like
they're they're in a town of 60 people
down there at kitty hawk building wind
tunnels uh recalculating the numbers
that the textbooks should have had but
they're just like ad those aren't right
uh and and so then they they make this
happen
it's this incredible feat and
one of the wright brothers
goes from like having the first flight
where they covered like i think 120 feet
or something like that like this
comically short distance within his
lifetime he observes a human flying fast
enough to break the sound barrier and
like just seeing the trajectory of how
innovations and flight took off like i
never before that considered myself
really into flight or aviation or
anything like that but just as someone
who appreciates the scientific method it
was such a cool thing to explore so if
you have any interest in like
there's just so much history to be found
there so if you ever have the
opportunity uh i would highly encourage
you to check out the outer banks of
north carolina very very cool place had
a great time
all right so i think that does it for
this audio update or audio update it
does it for this podcast episode uh as
always we appreciate you for checking it
out and we will be back soon with
another one
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you